meanwhile as we shake off the pandemic
businesses all across the valley are
trying to meet growing demand customers
have needs but custom companies rather
are very short on staff yeah this
morning we're profiling a local
manufacturing company seeing a spike in
demand so good news for them mary jane
bellieso joining us live at body balance
systems in the southwest valley so a
look at how they're moving forward and
exactly what they do eridan good morning
john and heather good morning to you we
are live here in the body balance
warehouse where they focus on meeting
the health needs and also creating
technology to help those in the
community especially like this
red laser light
bed that we have here right next to us
i'm joined early this morning with
michael londo who's the ceo and michael
thank you so much for joining us you
know we talked a lot about the
manufacturing boom that you guys have
had over the last year especially with
trade shows coming back but now you're
facing another set of problems which
includes hiring people to keep your
business going correct and hiring's been
a tough issue
what are some of those issues you guys
are looking at
just
getting people to reply to your ads and
call and show up for the appointment
interviews
and even just keeping the job
but we know you guys are expanding so
you guys are trying to pretty much get
into a new space as well correct we're
trying to move into a new facility
towards the end of the year
and that's the nice thing here because
we know that business is not only in
demand locally but also out of state
correct so we sell nationwide
we're also working with some people are
helping us get into worldwide
and it's kind of nice too because we
already have you know some of your
customers looking into kind of getting
their hands on one of these and we're
also joined with dan lear and dan thank
you so much for joining us brian early
but you actually use this bed as well oh
i do i do uh the bed's incredible so
uh in 2017 i got diagnosed with an
incurable disease called amyloidosis i
went through a couple years of chemo
and as a result my body's just always
kind of sore so the red light therapy
what it does it stimulates the
mitochondria inside of the cells creates
energy through the atp and it helps the
cells heal
so it's almost like a an energy boost
when you when you lay here so when i get
out of the bed in 15 minutes i feel more
revived refreshed
and it just helps me feel better it's a
it's a healing process and people are
loving it it's great for luxury spas
it's really catching catching on right
now and michael makes the most advanced
bet in the world
our bet is second to none as far as in
the industry so we're just taking off
wow yeah absolutely i mean thank you
both so much for joining us brian early
it's great to hear that business is
booming and also most businesses too are
trying to get over some of those needs
and demands that you guys are facing as
well reporting live mary jane belliesa
live local now